اعلن النظام السوري اصابه خمسه عسكريين
جراء ما سماه عدوانا اسرائيليا بالصواريخ
على مواقع في حمص وريفها كما اعلن الحرس
الثوري الايراني مقتل اثنين من مستشاريه
العسكريين
بضواحي دمشق فجر الجمعه وتوعد بالرد من
جانبها قالت تل ابيب انها تكبد ما سمتها
الانظمه التي تؤيد الارهاب خارج حدود
اسرائيل ثمنا باهضا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دوافع تصعيد
الحكومه الاسرائيليه هجماتها في سوريا
واستهدافها مستشارين ايرانيين وما الاهداف
التي تسعى الى تحقيقها عبر هذا التصعيد
كيف نقرا ردود فعل ايران على استهداف
اسرائيل مستشاريها في سوريا وما العوامل
التي تحكم طبيعه واشكال هذه الردود وما هي
المالات المحتمله لهذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي
في سوريا وكيف يمكن ان ينعكس على استقرار
المنطقه ومصالح دولها
[موسيقى]
في هجوم هو السابع الذي تنفذه اسرائيل
داخل الاراضي السوريه منذ بدايه العام
نقلت وكاله الانباء السوريه الرسميه عن
مصدر عسكري قوله ان خمسه عسكريين اصيبوا
وان خسائر ماديه وقعت جراء ما وصفه المصدر
بانه عدوان اسرائيلي بالصواريخ على مواقع
في حمص وريفها المصدر العسكري اضاف ايضا
حسب نقلت عنه الوكاله الرسميه ان الدفاعات
الجويه السوريه اسقطت بعض تلك الصواريخ
وفيما يتصل بنتائج غاره اسرائيليه سابقه
ضربت ريفا دمشق فجر الجمعه اعلن الحرس
الثوري الايراني مقتل احد مستشاريه
العسكريين وهو النقيب مقداد مهقاني بحسب
الحرس بعد اصابته بجروح في تلك الغاره
التي اودت كذلك بحياتي مستشار ايراني اخر
وشدد الحرس الثوري على ان ما سماه جريمه
الكيان الصهيوني المجرم لن تمر من دون رد
وفي اسرائيل التي عاده ما تلتزم الصمت في
مثل هذه المواقف قال رئيس الحكومه
بنيامينه ياهو الذي يواجه متاعب داخليه
جيم وتعقيدات في علاقته بالحليفه واشنطن
قال ان اسرائيل تكبد الانظمه التي تؤيد
الارهاب خارج حدودها ثمنا باهظا وفق
تعبيره
ولما نجده
اولا نحن نتحرك ونقاتل المخربين وقد قضت
قواتنا في الاشهر الاخيره على عشرات منهم
واعتقلت المئات امنح الدعم الكامل للشرطه
الاسرائيليه على تصفيتها مخربا في جبل
الهيكل نهايه الاسبوع الماضي ثانيا نحن
نكبد الانظمه التي تؤيد الارهاب خارج حدود
اسرائيل ثمنا باهظا واقترح على اعدائنا
الا يغرهم الخلاف الداخلي بيننا
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الناصره
الدكتور سليم بريك استاذه العلوم السياسيه
بالجامعه المفتوحه والخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه وتنضم الينا من الدوحه
الدكتوره فاطمه الصمادي الباحثه الاولى في
مركز الجزيره للدراسات والخبيره في الشان
الايراني مرحبا بكما دكتور سليم بريك
سنبدا معك طبعا هناك ابعاد كثيره حول كل
هذه التطورات ولكن لو بدانا من البعد
الداخلي من الازمه الداخليه التي تعيشها
حكومه نتنياهو بسبب
التعديلات القضائيه الجاريه كيف يمكن فهم
تكثيف الهجمات
الاسرائيليه على اهداف ايرانيه في سوريا
ارتباطا بهذا المعطى الداخلي
مساء الخير هو فعلا ممكن نحلل ما يحدث من
هجمات على سوريا بعده مستويات
ولكن على مستوى المحلي او على المستوى
الداخلي في دوله اسرائيل في عده رسائل
اسرائيل تريد ان ترسلها
لايران نحن سمعنا وزير الدفاع جالنت يتهم
ايران وحزب الله بترتيب العمليه التي نفذت
في ميغيدو والتي حتى الان اسرائيل لم ترد
عليها وهذا يمس بقوه الردع الاسرائيليه
ولذلك كان يجب ان يكون رد من وجهه النظر
الاسرائيليه طبعا اسرائيل تختار دائما
اهداف التي يكون فيها ايرانيين او سوريين
ولكن ان لا يكون فيها عناصر من حزب الله
لكي لا يكون هناك تصعيد امام حزب الله
ولذلك على هذا الصعيد اتت العمليه الهدف
الثاني هو طبعا ارسال رساله كما تفضلتي
بان الامور الداخليه في دوله اسرائيل
والخلافات حول قضيه الانقلاب ومحاوله
الانقلاب
تؤثر على الجهه الامنيه وانه حتى لو كان
وزير الدفاع حتى الان نحن لا نعرف اذا كان
اقيل ام لم يقال لانه لم يتلقى رساله
اقاله ومع هذا فان اجهزه دوله اسرائيل
الامنيه تعمل بشكل طبيعي
وتقوم بكل واجباتها ولا يؤثر النقاش
السياسي على رد فعل اسرائيل في هذه
الحالات ولو نظرنا الى المعطى الاشمل
المعطى الاقليمي ما يتعلق
بالتقارب الايراني مع السعوديه ما يتعلق
ربما
اعاده تطبيع علاقات عربيه مع النظام
السوري في من هذه الزاويه كيف يمكن النظر
الى الرسائل الاسرائيليه من وراء هذه
الهجمات
اسرائيل تلقت الصدمه او مفاجاه غير متوقعه
كانت بعمليه التقارب الايرانيه السعوديه
والابتعاد الاسرائيلي السعودي من السعوديه
يعني نتنياهو صرح قبل الانتخابات بان
الاتفاقيات افراها ستتوسع بشكل كبير جدا
وما حدث والعكس تماما تقارب سعودي ايراني
بمباركة صينيه او بوساطه صينيه الان هذا
يؤثر جدا على منطقه الجبهه السوريه من عده
اسباب اولا التقارب السوري هذا قد يؤدي
الى ضغوط على الولايات المتحده لكبح
اسرائيل ومنعها من الاستمرار واذا استطاعت
الدول العربيه ان تؤثر في هذا الاتجاه هذا
يقلق اسرائيل وراينا التقارب مثلا زياره
وزير الخارجيه السوري الى مصر الان
التقارب مع السعوديه وكل هذه الامور التي
هي عمليا ليست في صالح اسرائيل مناحي
الاستراتيجيه القضيه الثانيه التقارب
الايراني السعودي سيخفف من حده التوتر في
اليمن وعلى هذا الاساس تزيد من قوتها ومن
دعمها لحزب الله وهذا ايضا مقلق من ناحيه
اسرائيل ولذلك هي تريد الاستفاده من الوقت
وباسرع وقت ممكن
تستمر بضرباتها وان تمنح حزب الله من
الحيازه اسلحه استراتيجيه فارقه التي قد
تغير قواعد اللعبه في بين اسرائيل ولبنان
دكتوره فاطمه الصمادي ماذا عن القراءه
الايرانيه للدوافع من وراء هذه الهجمات
وتكثيفها في الايام الماضيه
فعلا شهد التكثيفا في الايام الماضيه
لكنها تاتي استمرار
المعركه الدائره في منطقه الظل او في
المنطقه الرماديه بين ايران واسرائيل
والتي اخذت بعدا متصاعدا منذ 2017 والهدف
الاسرائيلي المعلن باخراج ايران من من
سوريا
والقضاء على اوراق القوه الايرانيه ومن
ضمنها هذا النفوذ الاقليمي
لكن هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي مرتبط باكثر
من ناحيه واحده منها ان ايران فعليا بدات
تخفف من
تعداد قواتها في سوريا لانها تعتقد بان
التسويه السياسيه في طريقها الى ان تصبح
واقعا وانها استطعت ان تبني نفوذا لم يعد
بحاجه الى وجود هذا هذا النوع من القوات
في سوريا المساله الثانيه ان القوات التي
يتم استهدافها اما انها عناصر لها علاقه
مباشره بمواجهه اسرائيل او عناصر فنيه من
الحرس الثوري متخصصه في الموضوع الدفاعات
الجويه والتي تعمل منذ فتره في سوريا على
تعزيز الدفاعات الجويه السوريه هذا من
جانب من جانب اخر اسرائيل تحاول ان ترسل
رسائل بان بانها ما زالت قادره على ان
تفعل في المنطقه بمعنى انها تريد ان تجذب
اليها الامريكي بغيه التصعيد ضد ايران
بالنسبه لايران فهذه
الضربات هي بالفعل لها تاثير على صعيد
المواجهه مع اسرائيل لذلك نحن وجدنا ان
قاده الحرس في الاشهر الاخيره يؤكدون انهم
يقومون بالرد على الضربات الاسرائيليه وان
عدم الاعلان عن الرد لا يعني انه لا يوجد
هناك
الرد على هذه الهجمات لكن طبيعه التصريحات
الايرانيه في الايام الاخيره او بالنسبه
لاستهدافات الاخيره تقول بان نوع التصعيد
مع اسرائيل سياخذ بعدا اكثر علنيه في في
المستقبل المساله المهمه الاخرى تتعلق
ايضا بكل الحراك الدبلوماسي الدائر الدائر
في المنطقه لا يمكن التقليل باي شكل من
الاشكال تطور العلاقات مع السعوديه واضح
ان هناك قرار سياسي صلب على صعيد استعاده
العلاقه مع السعوديه والوصول معها الى عدد
من التسويات بشان ملفات معقده
ومن ضمنها مساله في سوريا من الواضح ان
ترتيبات العلاقات السياسيه مع النظام في
سوريا تاخذ بعدا اخر بمعنى ان الحل
السياسي في سوريا ياخذ بعدا عمليا وهناك
اجتماعات ستكون بين تركيا وروسيا وايران
بشان بشان سوريا والحل السياسي لذلك اعتقد
بانه هناك محاوله
اللعب في الوقت الضائع على صعيد توجيه
ضربات لايران الدكتور سليم بريك ماذا عن
الرسائل الاسرائيليه ايضا للطرف الامريكي
هناك ازمه الان مع الولايات المتحده بسبب
معارضه الولايات المتحده
لمدينه ياهو بهذه الاصلاحات القضائيه كما
تسم ى وكانت هناك رسائل امريكيه للحكومه
الاسرائيليه تقول يجب يعني اعطاء الاولويه
لمواجهه ايران للتقارب مع السعوديه في هذا
الاطار كيف يمكن فهم الرسائل من وراء هذه
الهجمات الاسرائيليه
واضح ان احنا موجودين في ازمه
ازمه بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده بين
العمليه هي بين البيت الابيض والحكومه
الاسرائيليه وليست بين الدول عمليه
التنسيق بين الجيوش الاسرائيليه
والامريكيه هي عدم مستوى عالي ولكن طبعا
هناك قلق من الناحيه الامريكيه بالنسبه
لكل ما يتعلق
بالوضع الداخلي في اسرائيل
والامكانيات التي تواجه حكومه نتنياهو في
هناك غضب جامح ضد نتنياهو وحكومه نتنياهو
المركبه من احزاب فاشيه وكل هذه الامور
ولكن هناك نقاشات بين اسرائيل الولايات
المتحده اولا نحن هذه النقاشات يعني
تاريخيا نحن نتذكر طبعا خطاب نتنياهو في
فتره اوباما التي كانت عمليه اهانه
لاوباما في بيته في في الولايات المتحده
وباعتقاد بايدن ما زال يذكر هذا وهذا يخلف
التي لا تستطيع اسرائيل تتغاضى عنها ولكن
في نهايه المطاف بكل ما يتعلق بايران هناك
ايضا وجهه نظر مختلفه بين اسرائيل وبين
الولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده ينصب
باهتمامه على القضيه النوويه بينما
اسرائيل تهتم اكثر من القضيه النوويه
بتغلغل ايران الى الشرق الاوسط الى سوريا
الى لبنان وكل ما يتعلق بهذا الموضوع هذا
يخلق اسرائيل اكثر
ولهذا السبب نحن نرى الضغط الاسرائيلي في
سوريا القضيه الثانيه وباعتقاد في هذا
الموضوع يوجد تفاهم معين بين اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده هو ان تصل سوريا بنفسها
الى استنتاج بان الوجود الايراني لا يزيد
من الامن السوري وبالعكس هذا قد يؤدي الى
المسج في الامن السوري كما نرى طول الوقت
يعني احنا شايفين نقطتين ضعف بالنسبه
لايران النقطه الاولى هي التغلغل
الاستخباراتي القوي الاسرائيلي في قلب
ايران تقريبا في كل الاجهزه الايرانيه
ونحن نرى دقه
الاصابات القضيه الثانيه والنيران لا
تستطيع عمليا نحن راينا مثلا ان حاولت في
اليونان ان تنتقم من اسرائيل وفشلت
الموساد استطاع ان يكشف هذه العمليه
وباعتقاد هذه ايضا رساله لايران بان
اسرائيل تتمتع بقدره استخباريه كبيره جدا
وهذا يغير الموازين بين في نفس الاطار رد
فعل الحكومه الايرانيه على مقتل
المستشارين الايرانيين بغاره انفجر الجمعه
الاسرائيليه قرب دمشق جاء على لسان
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه ناصر كنعاني
الذي قال ان دماء المستشارين العسكريين
الايرانيين في سوريا لن تضيع هدرا وان
بلاده تحتفظ بحقها في الرد على اسرائيل في
الزمان والمكان المناسبين وصف المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه استمرار الغارات
الاسرائيليه على سوريا بانه انتهاك
لسيادتها ووحده اراضيها وا ستمرار لدعم
الارهاب بحسب تعبيره دكتوره فاطمه الصمادي
ذكرتي قبل قليل انه اذا كنا لا نسمع بالرد
هذا لا يعني ان ايران لا ترد وهي تقول
المسؤولون الايرانيون يقولون انهم يحتفظون
بحق الرد في الزمان والمكان المناسبين
ولكن في هذه الظروف الاقليميه التي تشهد
تقاربا ايرانيا عربيا هل من مصلحه ايران
الرد
لا ايران لا تريد تصعيدا في هذه الفتره
لاكثر من من سبب اولا هي تريد ان مسار
اولويات الجوار ان ياخذ بعده الناجح الى
ابعد مدى بمعنى ان تاخذ العلاقات السعوديه
الايرانيه شكلا فيه اكثر من مجرد التهدئه
وعوده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بمعنى حل
حالات بعض الملفات الاشكاليه مثل اليمن
سوريا وغيرها من الملفات لذلك فهي تحتاج
الى هذا
الهدوء المساله الاخرى هي ايضا تحتاج الى
ان
تقوي من مساله ايجاد بدائل عن
بدائل اقتصاديه
نتيجه
العقوبات والحصار ولذلك ايضا تحتاج الى
التهدئه على هذا الصعيد بمعنى انها تحتاج
الى اعاده بث الحياه في اقتصادها المتاثر
بص كبيره جدا وعدم الرد دكتوره فاطمه عدم
الرد كيف يمكن ان يكون صدى في الداخل
الايراني في الحقيقه هو منذ منذ سنوات
اصبحت هذه المساله مساله اشكاليه محرجه في
الداخل في الداخل الايراني بصوره كبيره
جدا حتى داخل اوساط الحرس الثوري هناك
نقاشات كبيره جدا حول الرد وعدم الرد لانه
اصبح هذا الاستهداف وهذا هذه الاختراقات
المتزايده هي مؤشر ايضا على خلل امني كبير
لذلك فهي بالفعل نقطه محرجه في الداخل
الايراني وتحرج الحكومه الايرانيه امام
مواطنيها من جهه ومن جهه اخرى ايضا هي
توجه ضربه للخطاب الايراني في بعض المسائل
بمعنى الحديث عن ان التواجد او النفوذ
الايراني في الاقليم هو في باب منه للضمان
الامن داخل ايران لكن عندما تصل العمليات
ايضا لاستهدافات الى داخل طهران فهذا ايضا
نقطه اشكاليه كبيره جدا وفي ظني ان ايران
تدرك هذه المساله جيده لكنها تحاول ان
تحدث موازنه بين اولوياتها في هذه المرحله
وهي اولويات صعبه في الحقيقه دكتور سليم
بريك هل بهذا التصرف يعتقد نتنياهو وتعتقد
هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه انها قادره على
قلبي مسار الامور الحادثه في المنطقه
انا لا اعتقد باعتقادي انه حكومه اسرائيل
تدرك بان هناك تحركات على مستوى كبير
التقارب سعودي وغالبيه الدول الخليج مع
سوريا
راينا مثلا التقارب السوري المصري
هذا التقارب له تاثير كبير جدا على
الاقتصاد السوري وايضا على لبنان لبنان
طبعا الان تنهارت اقتصاديا بسبب نقاش حول
حزب الله
والسعوديه طبعا كانت تعارض حزب الله والان
على ما يبدو هذا الوضع سيتغير كل هذا يؤثر
سلبا على على اسرائيل وواضح بانه تقارب
بين العرب عاده هو ليس في صالح دوله
اسرائيل القضيه الثانيه
المهمه هنا انه امام بشار الاسد الان
تنفتح امكانيات كثيره لم تكن مفتوحه امامه
وهو يستطيع الان ان يناقش الشركاء هو
يستطيع الان ان يكون اقوى حتى امام ايران
يعني حتى الان ايران لا تستطيع ان تحمي
سوريا من الضربات الاسرائيليه باعتقاد
مره ونحن نتحدث الان عن تسع مرات من بدايه
السنه قامت اسرائيل بقصف اماكن في سوريا
وعادت بسلام
ولم يحدث شيء
وباعتقادي ايضا من الناحيه الاستخباريه ان
تقوم اسرائيل باستهداف ضابط استخبارات
ايراني مهم جدا بكل ما يتعلق
بالسلاح بسلاح حزب الله بالمسيرات بكل
الاسلحه بدقيقه وتدقيق الاسلحه كل هذه
الامور تدل بان القدرات الاسرائيليه اولا
من ناحيه الاستخباريه طبعا كما قلت قبل في
السابق وايضا من ناحيه القدره على ضرب هذه
الاهداف بدقه ومتى تريد هذا رساله هامه
جدا من وجهه نظر اسرائيل للدول العربيه
لان القوه التي ما زالت كبيره في شرق
الاوسط هي القوه الاسرائيليه على المستوى
الداخلي هذه الهجمات وتكثيفها هل هي قادره
على انقاذ نتنياهو من المازق الداخلي
لا باعتقادي انه لا علاقه بين الامور
نتنياهو موجود في مازق طبعا نتنياهو يراوغ
الان هو اوقف حاليا الانقلاب
ويتحدث عن مناقشات في بيت رئيس الدوله
ولكن في نهايه المطاف هذه مراوغه لا اكثر
ولكن ما يقلق نتنياهو الدعم الامريكي
القوي للقوه الديمقراطيه في اسرائيل كما
راينا من الرئيس بايدن هذا الامر الذي
فعلا يقلق اسرائيل جدا والان نتنياهو
اليوم اعترف بان ان محاوله الانقلاب اثرت
على الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي بشكل السلبي وعلى
الامن الاسرائيلي بشكل عام بسبب
ما رايناه من معارضه قوى عسكريه ضباط جيش
والى اخره
فيما لو استمرت هذه السياسه الاسرائيليه
بتكثيف الضربات على الاهداف الايرانيه في
داخل سوريا بينما ايران كما ذكرتي معنيه
بالتهدئه وتعزيز هذه التهدئه في المنطقه
كيف ستتصرف في المرحله المقبله في ظل
اولويات لديها
لا يعني بان ايران ستسقط
خيار مواجهه اسرائيل في كما قلت في
المنطقه الرماديه بمعنى ان حرب الظل ستبقى
مستمره بين ايران واسرائيل
ايران لديها قناعه بان
لابد من احداث نوع ما يشبه الانتفاضه في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله ولذلك هي لا
تحدث هذا التجزئه في جبهه المواجهه مع
اسرائيل بمعنى انها ترى ان دعم مثلا
مقاومه الفلسطينيه هو نوع من المواجهه مع
اسرائيل في ظني انه ستاخذ هذه المواجهه
بعدا اكثر تصعيديا اذا وصلت الى ورقه حزب
الله بمعنى انه اذا حدثت هذه المواجهه بين
حزب الله واسرائيل فهي ستاخذ بعد تصعيدي
بمعنى اننا سنشهد حربا ولي مواجهه في
منطقه
الظل وهذا ايضا خيار ليس مسقط بالنسبه
للايرانيين لكنها تحاول ان تدير مساله
الاولويات كما قلت
بفعل حاجات الداخلي الايراني بفعل
الضغوطات الاقتصاديه وبالفعل تجنب ايضا
المواجهه على صعيد برنامجها النووي شكرا
جزيلا لك يا دكتوره فاطمه الصمادي الباحثه
الاولى في مركز الجزيره للدراسات والخبيره
في الشان الايراني ضيفتنا من الدوحه وشكرا
للدكتور سليم
بالجامعه المفتوحه والخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه ضيفنا من الناصره
الى هنا مشاهدينا نصل الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا
لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]